Sheila:
I used to have this mean,
critical voice in my head.
♪ "I Am What I Am" by Gloria
Gaynor ♪
Shut up!
Sheila:
But I committed to my recovery,
and I got better.
♪ So come take a look ♪
Sheila:
But sometimes I wonder if that
voice is what got me here.
♪ Give me the hook or the
ovation ♪
Producer:
Are you ready?
Oh yes. I certainly am.
-♪ I am what I am ♪
-[electrical buzzing]
Hi, I'm Sheila D. Rubin.
Sheila:
Let's move!
Greta:
You are a national television
personality now.
We're building a place for women
to be free of judgement.
[cheering]
We should offer meditation.
Lamaze!
Yoga!
Pottery! Lesbians!
Yes! What?
We're brainstorming, there's no
bad ideas!
Yes!
Greta:
We are on the precipice of
something big.
Greta:
There's just one problem.
♪ I am what I am ♪
Greta:
Kelly Kilmartin.
Ernie:
She beat you to the punch.
Greta:
She's the most famous fitness
star.
I'm better than you.
♪ I bang my own drum ♪
Sheila:
Oh no.
They're looking at you.
Sheila:
She's in my head.
Kelly:
Fame begets scrutiny.
She's fake and a liar.
Every time I think you have hit
bottom you manage to sink even
lower.
This is really starting to scare
me.
You don't want to slow down now,
do you?
John:
So close to the top.
Greta:
I was hoping it wouldn't come to
this.
Just kidding I was dying for it
to come to this.
Greta:
It's go time.
This is more than just a
business for me, this is my
life!
Sheila:
I built this.
I am Body by Sheila.
♪ I am what I am ♪
You're just hanging on by a
thread.
Kelly:
Just waiting for that moment to
snap.
Leave me alone!
Kelly:
I thought you were on a healing
journey.
I am on a healing journey!
We have put everything on the line!
[tires screech]
Greta:
What if it doesn't work?
I won't let it happen.
[gun clicks]
Isn't one of the steps in your
recovery, integrity?
Recovery's a long road.
♪ I am what I am ♪